so what's the deal well hurricanes
clearly the worst Seinfeld ever the
Seinfeld imitate you yeah every once in
a while he pretends he's broke
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean seriously what what is it that
makes a hurricane hardly okay so I can
tell you sort of the physics of a
hurricane
all right the ocean we think of as just
a place to dip your feet in or a sail
across or to fly over it is a
fundamental driver of what goes on in
Earth's atmosphere what's the hottest
month not June that's gonna be July or
August right part of that time delay
comes about because the ocean is up
taking this heat that's it okay so one
of the great drivers of everything that
happens on earth is the ocean okay
because it's a big up taker of many
things of heat from the Sun of carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere you can just
absorb it all right and then come out
later so what happens hurricane season
is after we have peak heating of Earth
in the northern hemisphere okay peak
heating is in June when the sun's angle
on the earth's surface is at its highest
okay and then the Sun is working its way
down we're approaching fall and winter
but the ocean which had been up taking
that heat is now given some of that back
and so the hotter the ocean is relative
to the air the more you have unstable
air above it and warm moist unstable air
don't go there warm we're working
together to moist unstable air yes is a
recipe for making clouds okay okay right
okay so it's moist and warm so so it's
moist so it's got water vapor in it it's
warm so it's warmer than a ceramics
it'll want to rise as you rise it gets
to cooler and cooler air temperatures
and when you're cool that the air can't
hold that much water
in vapor anymore and it condenses out
makes clouds right that's it okay warm
moist unstable air you get clouds so
watch what happens where this zone kicks
in has low air pressure mm-hmm Wow if
your cloud anywhere and there's high
pressure over here in low pressure over
there where you going
I'm going over to the love you're going
to the low-pressure that's the high
pressures pushing you the worse when she
pulled ya sister
all the clouds head towards the
low-pressure system right all of them
clouds okay so no watch if you come in
from the sides all fine you just come
straight in straight okay no watch if
you come in from below I'm coming from
you got a picture of this now these are
rotating earth do you realize the
equator is moving faster than we are
of course because it has a bigger
circumference light like a record on a
record player oh my god it's like a
merry-go-round right like a regular the
outer horses are moving at whatever
animal it is they're moving faster
because they have a bigger circumference
yet they all finish one circle at the
same time all right
so watch so I'm trying to get to that
low-pressure system and I'm closer to
the equator than it as I go towards it
my sideways motion exceeds the sideways
motion of the parts of the earth I am
now passing over right I exceed that so
I'm trying to aim for the low-pressure
system but I overtake it right off to
the right what's me wait now I'm a I'm a
cloud north of the low-pressure system
right and I try to go towards it but I'm
going slower than it right so I come in
also to the right behind it okay
and so this forces a circulation in the
low-pressure system that is
counterclockwise and all clouds are
trying to get there at the same time and
you have a storm all the moisture is
being gathered up from all the region
right and putting it and that low
prejudice at one point and that's why we
have these arbitrary definitions if it's
above this speed it's a tropical storm
if the rotation speed is even higher
then it's a hurricane so the lower the
pressure is in the low-pressure system
the more potent it is of gas
during clouds from farther away and this
creates a basically a circulation and
it's true for all low pressure systems
in the northern hemisphere so what are
whatever you call them what in the
Pacific is it a cyclone and whatever
trapples will depress yeah whatever
tornadoes monsoons what even tornadoes
if we look at the circulation it's
counterclockwise
there are rare exceptions in a tornado
case you can have something that'll sort
of force it and it'll overcome what the
earth is trying to do to it but
basically all of this is
counterclockwise and then people say how
about my toilet which way does my poop
go down the hole it goes down whichever
way the Jets are pointing in your toilet
oh the rotation of the earth
don't Kant doesn't care about the radius
in your toilet right ok a little too
small it's a little too small a little
too small let's just mark where it goes
from the edge of the toilet to the
middle the rotation there there's a
non-factor that's there you can
calculate how much effect that is it's
it's swamped by anything that's going on
inside the toilet it's specially the
Jets that's it so into the southern
hemisphere all of this happens the other
way and storms then turn clockwise
that's so that you get a hurricane and
so the warmer the earth is the more
moisture gets evaporated into the air
and the more moisture there is to make
clouds and okay so the more whether you
have we associate weather with what the
water in the air is doing is it coming
out as hail sleet snow rain that we call
that wet it's and it's all water it's
all water it's just water twelve ways
that's it Wow yeah right is there a name
for just the swirling yeah yeah that's
it so this this was first studied by
physicist named Coriolis and so it's
called the Coriolis force or the
Coriolis Pavia they call it force it's
really not a force it's just I have a
different I'm do I will overtake the
low-pressure system headed towards it in
the northern hemisphere and if you look
at it's like something's pushing it to
the side and so in that sense there's
what we call a fictitious force but it's
still useful to think about it as a
thing
the Coriolis force of Coriolis force oh
yeah so you better hope if you have a
hurricane it comes very low tide like
right all right but hurricanes last
weeks as they come up the coastline
somebody is getting high tide on
landfall hurricane sandy in New York
City it what by the time it hit us it
wasn't a hurricane it was like a
tropical depression but it's really
large and was not only high tide but
there was the circulation of the air was
bullsh in the ocean towards the shore so
there's this sorcerer storm surge on top
of the high tides breached our walls I
was out of I didn't have electricity for
a week I lived downtown I was dark it
was truly Gotham nice it was the dark
night figure out if what you learn will
stick all right there's a quiz on the
Coriolis effect on hurricanes at
brilliant dot or say you're on a
merry-go-round that's rotating clockwise
and you throw a ball directly towards
the center how will you see the ball
move do you think it will travel in a
straight line or be curved to one side
now one of the many cool things about
brilliant is that you learn by playing
with interesting puzzles that build upon
each other did you ever imagine that
playing on a merry-go-round can
illustrate how hurricanes work I never
did but now it makes so much sense and I
understand how scientists think about it
even if you don't know something right
off the bat the site walks you through
various aspects of the concept so that
you have a deeper understanding and
apply that to various scenarios so to
keep learning go to brilliant dot org
slash Startalk
the first 782 of you will get 20% off
their annual subscription hey if you
want to see more videos from Starr talk
hit the subscribe button clockwise or
counter-clockwise depending on your
hemisphere and click the little bell so
you can get notified each time we upload
a video this bill is so Pavlovian it
really knows I like this video and as
always keep looking up unless it's a
hurricane coming then seek shelter
[Applause]
[Music]